- So you have this podcast that I love.
We talked about last week here.
So how's it going?
Because last time you
were on here, I love.
If you haven't heard of her podcast,
it's amazing.
So Minnie's questions are,
they're so deep, so thought provoking.
And the last time you were here
you actually asked me one of them.
And we didn't air it because I
was a little afraid to air it
because I was a very honest
and still going through a divorce.
But anyway, let's see the tape now.
- What question would
you most like answered?
- Oh.
(laughter)
- Okay, good.
This is good.
This is very good.
- What?
This might not air.
(laughter)
- When will divorce end?
It is.
I know, like, look, it took
two years for our divorce,
right? And so, and I
know people still in it.
That have been for like four..
It's already..
And I figured out from your question,
I was being funny
but I was being serious at the same time.
And also trying to be respectful
cause we were in it or whatever.
So I was like, oh, I just
don't wanna like, whatever.
So I didn't air it.
But I wanted to air it now
because these questions
they're seven of them,
that you ask.
And they're, you cannot go shallow
like with these questions.
Like you dive.
They're like really intense questions.
And the point was, I was
being funny about divorce,
if anybody has ever been through divorce,
but it's more than that.
It's grief.
It is grief and such a loss.
And it's like it strings along
and just drags you with it.
And luckily, I don't
read press or anything,
so I didn't have that portion of it.
But I was living it.
And so it was like, it's
one of those things where,
and I'm forgetting the question was when..
- What question would
you most like answered?
- Answered, yeah.
When will this get better?
- [MINNIE] I know.
- And I was being funny
but I was being real serious as well.